the loud house is taking the world by
storm many of its fans reimagined with a
popular cartoon character with the
plague in Star Wars
wait until you see Clyde lily and even
Ronnie give this video a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
let's check out 10 the loud house
characters music in star Louann the 14
year old Louann not only has a fantastic
sense of style she's also hilariously
funny Louann sense of humor would
definitely look interesting in a star
wars movie but can you imagine her as
Princess Leia this artist can this image
belongs to herobrine 666 1 2 1 from Bram
Union and we absolutely adore Luann's
new look as Princess Leia what do you
think could this cartoon jokester pull
off the ultimate Leia look we're not
sure why she's smiling like she has a
big secret but we're totally digging her
hair buns and although Louann is always
wearing her yellow outfit she seems to
be rocking Leia's white color Lincoln as
we all know the loud house revolves
around the 11 year old Lincoln loud he's
the only boy in the family and also the
middle child so it's safe to say he
deserves to have this story told from
his perspective but imagine what he'd
look like in Star Wars
here he is dressed as Luke Skywalker and
he looks absolutely amazing his white
hair matches suits white outfit because
totally imagine him in a lightsaber
battle
he'd probably even done it before in one
of its video games out of all the loud
house characters will show you Lincoln
definitely fits the Star Wars world best
Lisa get ready because things are about
to get really cute we all know the
four-year-old Lisa is the mastermind
behind all big ideas in the loud house
she was even able to open a portal that
connected their world to the world of
the Fairly OddParents so we thought we'd
pair up with a one and only our TV team
the two could definitely work together
and probably find solutions for all of
the world's troubles Fidesz ELISA looked
totally adorable as r2d2 if you're a fan
of our character you
we know she absolutely beat this outfit
but we have to admit she looks amazing
Lucy but if there's anyone that can
absolutely rock the Star Wars character
look it's definitely Lucy the
eight-year-old Lucy loud is one of the
darkest characters on the show even then
we often get a letter hilarious poems
and her excellent comedic timing here
she is dressed as Darth Maul she
definitely fits the part perfectly
check out that impressive lightsaber
this illustration belongs to superb
Lucario from tumblr who really did an
awesome job at showing Lucy's dark side
perhaps it's even too dark do you think
the Darth Maul version of Lucy would
still read poetry and carry around
Edwyn we have a feeling the lightsaber
would get replaced by Edwards head
plen'y we all know there are certain
characters on this show that would look
awesome as Star Wars characters but be
honest can you imagine Leni in Star Wars
the 16 year-old laynee is the most
fashionable person in the family so
could she give up her style to become a
Star Wars character according to Freeman
too from deviantART she definitely could
check her out
since Lennie already wears glasses
Freeman too made them even better by
turning them into the ultimate Star Wars
shades and she's definitely rocking the
fashionable look better than any other
character on our list but we have a
feeling her gun would probably only blow
bubbles as we really can't imagine Lenny
with an actual gun Clyde we don't talk
much about Clyde but that doesn't mean
that he's not an awesome character as
Lincoln's best friend Clyde has an
insight into the loud family like no one
else so it makes complete sense that
this little boy gets a huge crush on the
oldest of the loud family here's what
Clyde would look like in a Star Wars
setting we all know his best friends are
Lincoln and Ronnie so it only makes
sense with the three get themselves in
some kind of trouble like this this
illustration belongs to Cruden's from
deviantART and he did an awesome job at
portraying these three running away from
the stormtroopers what kind of trouble
do you think they got themselves into
Lily along with Clyde we also don't talk
much about Lily since she's still too
young but this 11 month old child just
got an amazing makeover Lily's
personality is still undeveloped and we
can't wait to see if she'll grow up to
be as smart as Lisa or as fashionable as
Lenny but paga Vita from tumblr
reimagined lily is a baby version of
bb-8 and it's one of the
things we have ever seen check her out
bb-8 is already cute but loli makes this
version even cuter we can imagine she'd
probably do a lot of damage by a
complete accident what do you think -
Lili handle being bb-8 Lauri speaking of
characters who would definitely fit in
Star Wars
we also think Lori would do a good job
she's pretty bossy but she can also be
feisty especially when one of her
siblings crosses any kind of boundaries
we have a feeling Lori would do an
amazing job as Darth Vader and it looks
like ffs I am go food ro 97 from
deviantART thinks the same we're
completely in love with Gloria's Darth
Vader or should we say Darth nori
although her blonde hair makes her look
slightly less intimidating she could
easily pull off the dark clothing and
she definitely has the right attitude do
you think princess Louann would give her
secrets and tell her where the rebel
base is Lisa and Lincoln we already
showed you Lisa and Lincoln separately
but we thought we'd show you what the
two would look like together Lisa and
Lincoln have a good relationship and
Lincoln often helps her with their
experiments credence from deviantART
reimagined Lisa and Lincoln as Star Wars
characters in Jedi training Lisa is of
course Yoda
because if we're completely honest this
world definitely fits her and of course
Lincoln is completely exhausted as the
Jedi because he's also pretty exhausted
taking care of his ancestors these two
would definitely be an excellent
addition to the Star Wars and we'd love
to see their adventures all characters
and here they are most characters from
the loud house reimagined as characters
in Star Wars
this illustration belongs to Freeman -
from deviantART and it's absolutely
amazing it really does look like the
real deal doesn't it we have Clyde lily
Lennie
Lauri Lola Lynne Lucy and Ronnie what do
you think do they fit in the typical
Star Wars setting we have a feeling the
loud kids would definitely turn this
Star Wars world into a much bigger mess
and break all rules along the way
after all that's precisely the reason we
all watch the show would you want to see
the loud house characters in Star Wars
let us know in the comments and that's
it for our video for more videos like
this one check out 10 the loud house
episodes that weren't for kids see you
next time